ما احتمالات ان تستخدم واشنطن القوه لما
تقول ردع الحوثيين لاستهدافه السفن
التجاريه في البحر
الاحمر الاحتمالات كبيره جدا غنوه على ما
يبدو نحن ازاء تحول نوعي في المقاربه
الامريكيه للتعاطي مع تداعيات الحرب
الحاليه الدائره الحاليا في قطاع غزه
وانتقالها من حرب محدوده في اطار قطاع غزه
الى حرب اقليميه هذا الامر كانت تحذر منه
امريكا بشكل او باخر كانت تتبع سياسه
تحذيريه الى حد بعيد وقائيه دفاعيه الان
نحن اذاء حديث متواصل ومتكرر ومتزايد حول
الانتقال من الدفاع للهجوم اذا وضعنا
تصريحات اليوم التي جاءت على لسان مسؤولين
امريكيين لموقع بوليتيكو والتي تتحدث عن
وجود خطط امريكيه لامكانيه توجيه ضربات
للحوثيين داخل اليمن بالتزامن مع الهجمات
التي شنت اليوم على بعض الجماعات المواليه
لايران في العراق خاصه جماعه النجباء
بالاضافه طبعا الى اختيار لصالح العرور
بالامس في او قبل يومين في بيروت هذا كل
يؤشر على تحول على ما يبدو وانتقال من
استراتيجيه الدفاع الى الهجوم وهذه محاوله
امريكيه من اجل ايضا حمايه اسرائيل فيما
يتعلق بحرب الد في قطاع غزه المشكله
الرئيسيه هنا ان ه هذا التحول قد يشي
بخسائر كبيره جدا خاصه الجانب الامريكي خص
بنتكلم على وجود قوات امريكيه متناثره في
كل انحاء الخليج العربي هناك بنك اهداف
امريكي قد يكون في مرمى نيران طهران
وحلفائها وبالتالي نحن اذاء امكانيه
الانتقال من صراع محدود الى صراع اقليم
واسع المدى مفتوح على كل السيناريوهات
اللافت ان مسؤولين في اداره بايدن ذكروا ل
بوليتيكو انه يعني يتم الحديث وبحث
احتمالات
ان ان تجر واشنطن الى حرب او تجر واشنطن
الى حرب في منطقه الشرق الاوسط ماذا نفهم
من هذا الكلام وما الذي
نترقبه هذا الكلام كلام يعني ان هناك
بالفعل مخاوف امريكيه جاده من انتقال
الصراع كما قلت قبل قليل من صراع محدود في
اطار منطقه يعني شمال
وشرق البحر المتوسط نتكلم على خاصه منطقه
قطاع غزه الى حد ما جنوب لبنان الى صراع
مفتوح على كل الاحتمالات ودخول اطراف
اقليميه وهنا انتقال مما يطلق عليه الصراع
المنخفض الحده اللي هو انتني كونفليكت الى
هاي انتني كونفليكت يعني صراع مرتفع لحد
بعيد وهذا يعني ان هناك بالفعل خطط
امريكيه قد يكون بالتعاون مع دول اخرى
خاصه بريطانيا من اجل توجيه ضربات نوعيه
للحوثيين في ظل عدم وجود تراجع من قبل
الحوثييين فيما يتعلق باستهداف سفن قد
تكون ذهبه لاسرائيل وايضا تهديد امن
الملاحه البحريه يجب ان نتذكر غنو ان هذه
المنطقه من العالم منطقه حيويه جدا
لامريكا ليس فقط فيما يتعلق بمصالحها في
المنطقه العربيه بل ايضا في مصالحها في
منطقه جنوب شرق اسيا بنتكلم على وجود قوات
امريكيه هناك في اليابان وفي كوريا
الجنوبيه وجود صراع مع الصين وبالتالي
هناك حاجه امريكيه لوجود نوع من السيطره
والتحكم في منطقه البحر الاحمر التحد
الرئيسي هو ان هذا التحشيد وهذه التعبه
الامريكيه لن تؤدي الى الاستقرار ستؤدي
بالعكس ستؤدي لوجود نوع من العسكره نوع من
الصراع وفتح المجال لكل
انواع الهجمات خاصه من قبل ايران في
المنطقه العربيه ما سمات هذا الصراع وهل
عفوا سيد خليل ما سمات هذا الصراع و هل
المنطقه منطقه الشرق الاوسط شهدت مثل هذا
الصراع ام ان الان هذه المنطقه في مرحله
جديده شوف يعني اشكال الصراع دي اشكال قد
تكون اشكال مختلفه قد تكون صراع من خلال
توجيه ضربات مباشره للحوثيين قد يكون من
خلال توجيه يعني ضربات عن بعد استبعد وجود
ما يطلق عليه يعني بوتس اند جراوند او
ارسال قوات امريكيه لليمن قد يكون استخدام
طيارات مسيره قد يكون استخدام اسلحه
متقدمه دما ضربات صاروخيه كما حدث قبل عده
ايام من الاستهداف عده زوارق يمنيه
تداعيات ذلك تداعيات طبعا تداعيات كبيره
جدا لو نتكلم على هذه المنطقه منطقه كانت
تدار بشكل او باخر بنوع من التناغم نوع من
التفاهمات ما يطلق عليه الامن الجماعي
الكتف سكيورتي نحن الان اذا مح للبلطجه و
السيطره
بالقوه لم اسمع السؤال ماذا عن السحات
الاخرى هذا سؤال مهم جدا لو بنتكلم على ان
هناك امكانيه لتوسيع الصراع فيما يتعلق
بالبحر الاحمر قد نشهد رد فعل في ساحات
اخرى خاصه الساحه اللبنانيه بالقطع طبعا
هناك امكانيه لحدوث نوع من التصعيد بل
ايضا في الساحه العراقيه والساحه السوريه
بنتكلم على ايضا وجود قوات امريكيه هناك
على الاقل في العراق 2500 جندي امريكي
موجودين هناك في قاعده عسكريه قرب الانبار
بنتكلم على الاقل على وجود من 800 ل 1000
جندي وضابط امريكي في قواعد عسكريه في
سوريا وهناك ميليشيات تابعه لايران بشكل
او باخر وبالت قد نشهد وجود هجمات نم على
القوات الامريكيه وهذا يعتبر مؤشر خطير
لماذا سبب مهم جدا بنتكلم على سنه
انتخابيه حاسمه لبايدن اي خسائر سياسيه اي
خسائر في الارواح الامريكيه قد تؤدي الى
وجود خسائر سياسيه داخل داخل امريكا هنا